Donald Trump's former campaign manager
Paul Manafort as you know by now
probably has made his fortune as a
political strategist for various
oligarchs and dictators all over the
world he's under investigation by the
CIA the FBI the NSA the Director of
National Intelligence the Treasury
Department and some of his question will
business questionable business dealings
are now pointing in the direction of
possible money laundering it's getting
worse and worse and worse for Paul
Manafort it's now being reported that
Paul Manafort bank accounts in Cyprus
are being investigated for money
laundering manna fort opened 15 bank
accounts in Cyprus in 2007 the accounts
were used to receive some of those
millions of dollars from Russian
billionaire Oleg Deripaska who he used
to do business with therapist kaput ins
sort of right-hand man he's been accused
by the United States being tied to
organized crime and when manna fort
opened those accounts Deripaska started
paying manna for the 10 million a year
that he was getting to run the probe
Hooten top propaganda campaign in a
number of different countries around the
world Lindsey Graham told NBC this is
something that disturbs me if true in
2012 one of the banks noticed suspicious
transactions on some of the accounts and
they asked Manafort for more information
about the account suspecting he's
laundering money man affort didn't
comply he immediately closed the
accounts as if that's really going to
make the problem go away and of course
in response to all of this a
spokesperson for man report says Paul
Manafort
doesn't remember why he closed the
accounts he paid eighteen point nine
million dollars to buy a media network
in Ukraine where he used to work for
pro-russian politicians but the court
documents say that the deal never went
through which means that there's
eighteen point nine million dollars that
supposedly were paid for that network
but now we're completely unaccounted for
which is possibly the money that was
laundered through these 15 cyprus bank
accounts it's all so shady there's a
2009 bank account
that manna foreclosed the same day that
a million-dollar deposit appeared in it
this is all according to experts exactly
what you would expect to see to move
money in a way that is designed to be
more difficult to track
Tom cardamom the managing director of a
DC nonprofit called global finance
integrity said quote there are some red
flags here it looks suspicious and any
bank that wanted to address money
laundering would certainly have looked
into the ownership of the company who
owned these accounts cypresses anti
money laundering
task force which they have because
Cyprus is a money-laundering haven has
handed over documents the United States
Treasury who are already investigating
that afford as you know this is not
looking particularly good for Paul
Manafort is it what strikes me is that
if Oleg Deripaska gave him millions of
dollars to set up a media network and
then he turned around and didn't do that
or the deal didn't go through yeah
wouldn't he expect his money back you
would think that would be the case right
unless Paul Manafort found another way
to appease him yeah or unless the entire
context of the transactions was just a
ruse to give the money to Paul Manafort
and the real goal here is that this was
all a sham there was never a deal to buy
the TV network or whatever it was all
just meant to create a ruse to sort of
account for money that is unaccounted
for and was subsequently laundered long
story short I think we can expect Sean
Spicer Trump's press secretary to keep
distancing from Matt affort like they've
been doing for weeks now days before the
the first set of recent Manafort
revelations went public Sean Spicer
started down playing the role of Paul
Manafort in the campaign's Agitos and he
was not a major player in the Trump
campaign he was the manager of the
campaign for a while okay so I'm
guessing now pat we can expect Sean
Spicer to come out there Oh Paul
Manafort yeah he looks like an unpaid
intern for the campaign who never met
Trump he worked in Iowa at the Iowa
office that's it he was a nobody in this
campaign oh if Trump saying I've never
heard of the KKK I've never heard of it
yes and Stanley Kubrick Stanley Kubrick
faked Paul Manafort guy never actually
existed that's been
next thing we're going to hear from Sean
Spicer this is trouble this is really
really big trouble and you've got Roger
stone who were scheduled to interview
next week if he doesn't cancel because
who knows what's going to happen with
him in the Russia investigation in the
next few days we will be talking to
Roger stone about this next week that's
exciting and also Paul Manafort should
definitely face some charges because he
worked in the US as an unregistered for
an agent yeah and that's a crime that
commit that warrants I think five years
in prison
oh yeah but crimes are relative in the
sense that if you're Paul Manafort
you're way less likely to be charged
with them even if you've actually
committed crime because you're in power
yeah no doubt about